I am Erin Fox on Twitter as Erin Fuchs
looks like a spelling mistake it's not
that's where you could find me and I'm
here to talk about learning react native
as a junior engineer I got hired at
Major League Soccer to build a brand-new
react native app straight from the start
so I didn't know much about react native
so obviously the first thing that I
googled was what is soccer I'm not a big
soccer fan so I I remember when I
interviewed they asked me they're like
are you here for the soccer are you here
for the tech and I was like I googled
what is soccer before I came to this
interview so I'm definitely here for the
tech but I love this gift because it's a
lot like how I felt I had no idea about
react native I had no idea about being a
software engineer and I didn't I just
didn't know much about much so I could
go on and on about being a junior
engineer but for the sake of this 10
minutes I just kind of cherry picked a
couple lessons that I've learned and
what my team has done to really have
successful first timers learning react
native so these are my five lessons of
learning react native the first one
jumping in headfirst it's terrifying
it's so scary being a first-time junior
I have so many questions and we're about
to build a brand new app for millions of
soccer fans around the world I don't
know I didn't know that a game is called
a match or I'm not sure what the
difference between props and state is so
jumping in headfirst is number one
number two walk before running so we
used a lot of technologies kind of as a
booster seat for us I'll get more into
that later so we started out small and
got a little bigger with that three
writing checks your API can cash so
understanding API is and where it comes
from it's like magic at first like wow
there's so much information here where's
it coming from
so it's something that juniors have no
much data about our information about
and for best way to learn is to teach
obviously I love this one because it's
not just valuable lesson for juniors but
people that work with juniors teach
juniors and mentor juniors and the last
one is stop drop and learn and this is
just kind of an environment that we
started doing on MLS and I'll get more
into that in a bit but I'm gonna go
ahead and jump right into the first one
here's a couple screenshots of our app
that we were using or created and I
remember when they first gave us the
Zeppelin slides I was like oh my gosh
like there's no way I couldn't even get
that MLS shield up there I just had so
many questions like where's this
information coming from and what it's
two and two mean and how can you play a
soccer game and nobody wins so a lot of
questions like that running through my
head but usually juniors are too scared
to ask questions they think you're
really busy or they just have a million
questions they don't want to ask too too
many so just always know that we always
have questions and you guys probably
know the answer you might not know the
answer but when you explain it to us you
might understand it Warren will get it
more so I just overall many questions
going on
so obviously but you might have noticed
some these components that Sam brought
up earlier so we had to really start
small and so the way that we did that
was with story book and story book was
awesome so coming in to MLS I only had
about a week of react experience so I
didn't know much about how to build
components or anything like that so
story but really gave me confidence to
like pump out these components that
we're building for our new app it's
total in isolation
I gave me confidence I didn't have to
get Xcode or Android studio up and
running so it really again
confidence-booster
think my first two to three months I
just build components and story book so
this is my very first component is a
button and I had no idea how much goes
into a button you can see here we have
the props coming in the fill color the
size the on press this is the way we
laid it out but story book it's just it
really gets rid of a lot of the noise
and for first-timers and for juniors is
just great too that this one button this
one component that I'm working on so I
highly recommend it if it's you have
juniors on your team or you're sorry now
with react native
another way that we really got rid of
the noise
was using graph QL how do you use graph
QL here class okay I love got QL cuz
when I first started out I was like oh
these queries are awesome like that's
all it is like it just magically as a
period so that's what I thought
thought it was I'll just magically of
making these queries and they would show
up but it's not only just a very popular
way of getting data for your app now um
it's excellent for us to work with
because I didn't know much about the API
is that we have and I didn't have to
learn everything in the api's I just
able to do option space and then all my
options were available for me so graphic
ul is really great for discovering what
data you have available and kind of
learn on your own aspect of it again the
command space really really saved me to
be able to see what was available and
then I was able to add it to copy and
paste it in our app here's an example of
our simple match query
I love graph mail because the
documentation well bonus is written for
you so really awesome to be able to just
figure out what information I could have
for a match style for a component while
I'm building it out in story book and it
really gives you a lot of confidence got
you can get all this information back
for you and then you just copy and paste
it you know what's gonna work
this is graphical what we're using we
use it probably every day I have a
lesson it's just a really great tool
that we use for everyone uses it from
seniors leads to juniors so really
really awesome the next part of this is
so I didn't do this on my own and they
weren't just okay here's story book
here's graph QL you're doing great we
did a ton of hair programming and I'm a
huge huge fan of pair programming we
would pair junior junior junior senior
senior senior it was just great to have
a buddy next to you to be able to ask
questions or just see how they write
their syntax so pair programming is
something that we did for first three
months every day or it was we still do
it now with more complex things but if
you ever have the opportunity to pay a
program with anyone about anything I
highly recommend it and I'm just a very
very big fan of it um so sometimes we'd
pair programmatic it just kind of get a
little crazy you know when you're Perico
and you just don't understand exactly
what's going on and it's
gets a little more complex so then we
would just be like whoa we need to have
a teachable moment and last night at the
speaker dinner someone was telling me
that a teachable moment is a bad thing
they're like oh you really messed that
up we need to have a teachable moment
about that but Emma less we see
teachable moment as a wage to stop what
we're doing and drop our laptops and
really figure out what your if she was
going on and figure out what what you
don't understand so we would huddle in
the conference room have a whiteboard
juniors are able to ask any questions
that we had so it's great to have that
safe space to be able to ask questions
or like say a wall I thought we did it
this way or like I thought props in the
state were the same thing but it was
great to be able to have that
environment to ask those questions and
have different levels of people have
members from the team there to answer
them so the first example I have here is
I always thought react native was just
like one app that you just made and
everybody could use it and everybody can
have it you could build anything you
wanted on it but we have a Brightcove
media player for Major League Soccer and
it's the bridges like I had no idea
about bridges so one of our teachable
moments was learning about that it could
be anywhere from 10 seconds to 10
minutes it's just a really really quick
little teachable moment another one was
graph QL so with our architecture in our
infrastructure I just like where is
graph you go in this I guess in the
database or is in here and this is when
we were at at lunch and all of a sudden
would be like moved everything on the
table and the ketchup packets became our
api's and the mason jars are at
databases our happy server was the
silverware and I just got it I really
got it so it's just interesting to see
to have these teachable moments like in
out of the office at lunch so it was
just awesome to be able to have that
experience in that just that kind of
team to ask questions when you're
starting out with react native so kind
of to wrap it all up the technologies
that we use there's so many out there
that are really benefit for juniors or
first-timers like react native story
book
and teachable moments there's a lot of
information out there that can really
help your entire team not just juniors
but seniors and teach to learn and
everything like that so in the end like
you might be very very confused whether
it's about soccer or whether you're just
starting out as a software engineer
trying to learn react native but
eventually like you start getting it
like this is awesome
like back native is actually very very
cool and then you celebrate cuz maybe
you're not a junior anymore and you
actually understand it so that's all I
got for you
[Applause]